[Música]
é michel luiz gustavo sou profissional
de educação física está e eu trouxe aqui
pra vocês hoje um pouco do nosso amor é
vida é um projeto que nós temos aqui na
praia do futuro sobre o surf adaptado os
uhf acessível
os uhf transformador é pessoas com
limitações com algum tipo de deficiência
é a gente percebeu que eles estavam um
pouco assim desacreditados tristes com
com o acontecido então a ferramenta surf
como a gente costuma falar ela veio pra
envolver e nos envolver com essas
pessoas ea nossa proposta é trazê las de
volta à sociedade no meio do esporte e
do meio de uma prática de esporte
radical não é o surf é um esporte que eu
acredito que para muitos tem um tenha
sido assim no passado têm uma
dificuldade teve uma discriminação e
hoje é um esporte que que é inovador que
pessoas que procuram movimentar o corpo
movimentar a sua vida eles vêem assim
cada vez mais se envolvendo e fazer essa
prática existe uma frase muito
interessante que que eu sempre escuto
sempre falo que a cura para tudo no
mundo vem da água salgada seja ela
lágrimas seja ela suor ou seja água do
mar mesmo então a gente tem como isso
que eu sou feliz seja transformador e
falando em transformação a gente fala
muito na questão de transformação do
corpo transformação do ser humano
transformação da mente dessas pessoas
essas pessoas com essas limitações
adquiridas ou pessoas que já nasceram
com essas limitações
era gente o para a gente poder pode
sentir que eram pessoas que tipo é
tinham um pensamento muito triste um
pensamento que eram pessoas diferentes e
através desse desse primeiro contato
desse convite que foi feito para essas
peças
esses deficientes digamos assim né que
não na verdade não são deficientes são
pessoas especiais
a gente hoje é entrar no espaço um
espaço que eles seguissem fechados a
gente hoje é sentir é uma corrente de
retorno um carinho deles o que a gente
pode também é fazer parte de uma vida a
fazer parte do do ser fazer parte do
meio deles e o nosso primeiro contato
foi lá para o ano de 1995 com um grande
amigo de um irmão não buscar a gente
chorou muito carinho por ele que era o
felipe cadeira como ele gostava de ser
chamada eram era um rapaz que estava
envolvido no meio no meio de todos
estava sempre nas praias com a gente
sabe estava sempre fazendo alguma
atividade na praia algum álbum frescobol
e esse cara ele tinha uma vontade imensa
de estar sempre ao nosso lado até que um
dia
despertou uma curiosidade dele poder
fazer essa vivência na água
muitos acharam loucura muitos achavam
impossível mas só ele tem essa vontade
extensa essa iniciativa eu achei isso
fabuloso cara grande era pesado era
forte
é isso em 95 a gente não tinha nenhum
nem nada falando sobre o esporte
adaptado assim o prometo
eu não tinha noção e falei vamos lá
vamos ver o que acontece
tipo peguei um da minha vida toda tipo
nasce já praticamente à beira da praia
então eu tinha um certo envolvimento num
certo uma certa adaptação ao mar e para
mim foi muito fácil
peguei esse cara voltei peguei a cadeira
de rodas aí arrastando ele uns quase um
quilômetro por que para o futuro vento
muitas variáveis vento corrente ondas e
um cara de quase 100 quilos eu conheço
meu peso que absurdo está ser daqueles
né
fica um pouco complicado mas vamos lá
tudo é uma questão de sobrevivência de
vivência de algo novo e isso tiveram
muitas barreiras né
felipe é um cara que é apaixonado pelo
esporte mas nunca tinha tido essa
vivência um cara de brasília
sua ficha do lago paranoá né e ele veio
para fortaleza ea gente começou a fazer
essas vivências com ele na água e o cara
se transformou o cara sempre chegava no
website é que a gente fala que lá atrás
lá no fundão ele sempre estava noite
site as pessoas ficavam curiosas
o rapaz cadeirante sempre passava na
cadeia ele chegava na praia na biruta
barraca lotado era barraca do momento
ele chegava na cadeira dele descendo com
a prancha do lado a gente puxava esse
cara andava quando chegava a noite saúde
e pagava melhor onda maior de fazer um
sufi do dia e fazer a cabeça era um cara
que estava superando transformando e
além de tudo ele era de igual a igual
comigo com você com todos que estavam na
água e isso foi o mais interessante de
tudo e com decorrer dessas brincadeiras
surgiram muitas outras propostas de
pessoas nos diferentes síndromes pessoas
amigas que falava poxa eu estava em
quinto tem condições de pegar um amigo
que é deficiente visual que ele é
deficiente auditiva a gente fazer uma
prática com ele na água
lógico então essas barreiras sempre
foram sendo superadas e foram-se sendo
sendo transformados e assim
isso me apaixonou isso me mudou minha
vida e eu tive aquela que era aquela
vontade teve aquele interesse de estudar
sobre o caso foi fui me especializar
filhos entrei no curso de educação
física me graduei isso ajudou a entender
mais sobre o corpo humano se entender
sobre limitações entender sobre o
próximo e partindo para tudo isso a
gente teve um trabalho típico com
pessoas com com pessoas amputadas
a gente teve que fazer todo um trabalho
de adaptação a essa pessoa ao meio fazer
um trabalho de mobilidade com essa
pessoa ao meio é fazer um novo caminhar
fazer uma nova subida fazer um novo
momento porque hoje é pessoas que têm
assim uma amputação
acredito que 90% são coisas são momentos
recentes acidentes de moto trânsito né
algo parecido são pessoas que estão ali
esquecidas também então estão procurando
algo pra poder é interagir socializar
com os demais então mais uma vez essa
ferramenta do sul fee é transformar
essas pessoas e traz e eles de volta ao
esporte esporte é maravilhoso é o
esporte é lindo eu acredito que que se
não fosse o esporte é eu não sei se eu
estaria aqui hoje eu não sei se estarei
aqui passando essa reflexão para vocês e
não sei como seria assim uma a minha
vida então o esporte para mim é tudo ea
gente também pode falar também um pouco
sobre a questão de poder reconhecer o
corpo gente eu acho que algum alguns
dias a assim mais alguns meses atrás eu
tive um problema no ombro que fazer a
cirurgia fiquei machucado por meses do
meu ombro esquerdo
tive dificuldade para dirigir e tive
dificuldade para dar minhas aulas tive
dificuldade dos atendimentos então
questões de três quatro meses eu fiquei
com o braço com a tipóia
foi horrível e eu fico a pensar como que
deve ser uma pessoa que tem uma perna
amputada que tem um braço amputado
uma pessoa que é cadeirante uma pessoa
que tem uma paralisia cerebral como que
deve ser a vida dessas pessoas e isso só
veio assim a a tocar mais assim no meu
coração e ar procurar ajudar mais e mais
as pessoas entender como essas pessoas
se sentem e como essas pessoas podem
tipo contribuir em minha vida e nas
vidas de todos vocês
então é esse tipo assim esse momento tem
sido um momento muito maravilhoso tem
sido muito prazeroso e poder reconhecer
e entender essas pessoas poder ajudá-las
e participar do esporte radical como os
o boj e além do mais é conseguir trazê
las de volta consegui socializar essas
pessoas a a assim ao mundo porque tipos
podemos dizer que eram pessoas que
sequer assim normais
hoje elas com essa limitação às vezes o
espaço mundo dela ela se fecha entre
quatro paredes
houve relatos dessas pessoas que já
pensar em alguns momentos sim em tipo
esquecer da vida esquecer do mundo
esquecer do próximo e isso me deixou
muito assim muito triste
no andar da carruagem é na prática
na conversa na troca de informações em
nossas reflexões eu pude perceber que
hoje esses super-heróis que é o que eu
falo porque são caras assim que eu sou
seu fã número um
são pessoas que tipo cresceram tanto na
vida pessoal como na vida social
são pessoas que hoje fazem parte de um
meio e que nos ensina a cada dia é como
assim a nossa vida é valiosa como como é
viver o dia é perfeito e com essa
transformação
eu pude eu pude perceber que tipo a
gente poder fazer bem ao próximo a gente
poder ajudar o próximo
eu estou me ajudando mais e mais e estou
aprendendo mais e mais com eles que essa
transformação de vidas essa
transformação de pessoas ela podem ver
como nosso amigo falou pode vir de uma
de um cordel pode vir de um uma
transformação do esporte radical dos uhf
e pode assim você acha que cada um de
nós a gente pode transformar a gente
pode fazer parte do próximo a gente pode
olhar para o nosso amigo ao lado e falou
assim eu quero
que ajudar eu quero fazer parte da sua
vida ea gente pode conhecer é a sua vida
assim mais assim aprofundada a gente
pode ver as dificuldades que ele tem e
procurar comparar com as tuas ea gente
vai poder perceber que a nossa vida é
maravilhosa que a nossa vida assim é um
céu estrelado
então gente é conhecer o próximo
conhecer suas limitações eu acredito que
vai se fazer é agradecer vai fazer
crescer bastante
é durante um etapa do circuito cearense
bodyboard ano retrasado
bush também tem uma experiência
maravilhosa
eu tive um convite de fazer uma vivência
com pessoas que eu nunca vi na minha
vida vi eram crianças com down síndrome
de down paralisia cerebral visual e no
ato eu conhecia do dia do dinheiro à
garota que ela tenha se contém uma
paralisia cerebral é o relato da sua mãe
é que ela tipo passava o dia deitada na
sua caminha não tinha um tipo único
movimento que ela tinha era um dos olhos
e com essa nossa prática do surfe
ela deu um sorriso ela movimentou a
cabeça e se movimentou braços e a mãe
relatou que alguns momentos em matérias
que a gente fazer durante algum evento
em algum campeonato ela ouve a voz da
gente pessoas que trabalharam com ela
nesse evento ea garota sorria na cama a
garota vibrava e isso me deixou muito
entusiasmado muito empolgado e é do dia
sempre que vem a fortaleza que é do
interior que ela vai fazer um
atendimento
ela vai até a escola e faz uma vivência
então isso pra mim foi fascinante
um outro caso marcante também do meu
grande amigo que o dadinho da dilma ele
é tem síndrome de down
ele seja fez vários trabalhos
o poder é tratar se tratar para poder se
envolver com pessoas e também teve um
relato do seu pai que e já fez vários
trabalhos com ele
o que o mais transformou sua vida por
incrível que pareça foi o suficiente
os uhf mudou seu pensamento surf mudou
sua forma de caminhar o surf mudou sua
forma de pensar
lógico que poderia ter feito outro
esporte mas deus é tão bom que ele
trouxe ele para o surfe mais um pra
poder ter essa transformação através
dessa ferramenta é o mais interessante
também que tem a ver que tem acontecido
na minha vida é esse cara não merece sim
esse cara é um amigo de 20 30 anos atrás
e durante alguns até três anos atrás eu
encontrei com ele novamente era um cara
que surfava era um cara que tava numa
todos os dias um cativo que eu pude
encontrar agora tetraplégico um acidente
de carro ele sofresse acidente estava
com a criança no colo o carro capotou
a criança não sofreu nenhum arranhão
poder entregou a frança prancha a
criança a um amigo é o seu pescoço virou
o cara tava tetraplégico passou anos e
anos e anos deitado para o estado na
cama e daí hoje o careçam de superação
o cara está surfando o cara só tem um
movimento da cabeça e sempre nos maiores
margens melhores margens está junto
eu ajudo sempre entrar na água dentre as
pernas deles ainda falou o fato
interessante eu falo assim mas sim abrir
as pernas para encaixar meu peito na tua
bunda ele com o me se eu não sinto nada
o perdão mas sim me desculpa eu vou lá
abre as pernas de encosta no peito na
bunda agente rima e sempre modificar as
maiores ondas então esse cara pra mim às
vezes eu penso na minha na minhas
complicações as minhas dificuldades e
quando eu lembro dele e que ele chama de
uma forma carinhosa neguim como é que tá
aí hoje estou hoje mas sim
então esse cara tem transformado vidas
esse cara tem sido assim pra mim é um
grande exemplo e vem assim atingido a
cada momento pessoas que tipo procura
entrar em contato com a gente procura
entender como funciona o projeto e
procuram saber é como que a gente pode é
teve pessoas concluiu imitações seja ela
qual for e e assim o que eu tenho que
falar pra vocês gente que o surf é
transformador
os uhf este movimento é teu corpo alma e
atualmente e os uhf faz você ser uma
pessoa melhor faz você poder está em
contato com a natureza que hoje nosso
criador jesus cristo eu queria mamar
para que a gente possa se deliciar e
possa se envolver possa estar mais
próximo dele
então é o que eu tenho a falar pra vocês
a imensidão do mar é enorme e tão enorme
quanto o nosso projecto amar a vida tá
então hoje é assim o que eu quero
agradecer a vocês a oportunidade de
poder falar um pouco sobre essa nossa
transformação com essa ferramenta surf o
bodyboard está em que a gente possa
estar transformando vidas e faz o
convite a vocês quem quiser que tem
tiver um amigo que queira traseiro para
poder fazer essa vivência estamos de
braços abertos aguardando por todos
vocês têm um bom dia é obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]